question dubé et le président du conseil
du trésor bonsoir monsieur dubé merci
d'être avec nous ce soir pour parler de
ce plan de relance est ce que des
infrastructures l'accélération des
infrastructures pour vous c'est vraiment
le coeur du plan de relance que le
gouvernement du québec met en place
c'est un élément très important
mes collègues notamment l'initiative et
bleu enfoncé sur les entreprises
le ministre gérard millet mesure pour
les individus en collaboration avec le
fédéral mais dans la concentration en
partie de se plaindre venir des
infrastructures pense qu'on sait
l'importance de l'industrie d'accord sur
dans le pib comme vous le savez alors
oui c'est un élément très important
qu'ils vous parlent et d'accélérer
d'alléger les processus d'autorisations
est-ce que c'est l'occasion idéale pour
vous de faire passer des projets plus
vite par la voie rapide sans se prendre
les pieds dans toutes sortes de mesures
administratives
mais effectivement on se rend compte
avec la crise si je peux faire un
parallèle nous suffit liant que hopper
est plus efficace au gouvernement je
pense au télétravail
on n'aurait jamais pensé qu'on pouvait
craindre car aux tables de travail qu'il
faisait à distance et on a vu qu'on
pouvait être efficace
on a vu avec la santé qu'on pouvait
faire de la télé médecins n'ont
maintenant ce qu'on est en train de
regarder c'est ce qu'on demande à
l'opposition de collaborer avec nous c
est ce qu on pourrait faire les mêmes
projets il fonde en respectant les lois
et plus agile plus efficace pour arriver
à ces projets leurs alarmes et objectif
c'est de d'enlever un petit peu de
bureaucratie mais de s'assurer qu'on va
respecter les lois et les règlements
mais comment être plus efficace mais
moins de bureaucratie là est-ce que
c'est moins de règles environnementales
par exemple alors j'aime beaucoup de
questions parce que vous donne un
exemple si un projet
aussi important vous avez donné les
exemples par exemple au niveau de
tramway sur deux soit longueuil à
gatineau ou à laval
il peut y avoir il y aurait un besoin
d'un bas le pape ne sera jamais mais ce
type e et peut-être améliorer c'est
combien d'études que ça prend pour
arriver au barkly la documentation que
l'on doit préparer est-ce que ça doit
prendre douze mois pour avoir la bonne
documentation ou si on peut le faire
dans la moitié du temps pour arriver
avec la même décision qui touche aussi
bien établie mais six mois six mois
plusieurs pardon excusez moi si moi
d'autorisation six mois de documentation
au lieu de 12 mois nécessairement ont
réduit les exigences environnementales
on va aller plus vite sur certaines
choses pour aller directement au projet
moi je vous dirais non parce que ce
qu'on veut faire c'est s'assurer que ils
exigent du bas on dirai ce que j'ai
toute la documentation nécessaire pour
donner le go à ce projet donne la
réponse à m oui ça va être à nous de
s'assurer que cette documentation alors
que ce faire dans une dans un processus
qui est par le passé et je pense qu'on
peut le faire en seconde les deux
prochaines années pour montrer si
justement les meilleures pratiques
peuvent être améliorés mais on ne
changera pas les lois mais il ya 202
projets il y en a une cinquantaine où on
veut accélérer ou à les lever sur
l'environnement et points bat à chaque
fois de toute façon c'est des
autorisations environnementales qui
existe sur différents projets qu'on va
vouloir accélérer ces suppôts dit c'est
pas tous les grands projets majeurs qui
ont sait pas tous les grands projets qui
sont majorque 3-1 de nombre il ya
d'autres mesures de minutes
environnement était très impliqué dans
cette décision alors au bord on va
expliquer dans les prochains jours en
discutant avec l'opposition
avec quels sont les niveaux d'impact sur
l'environnement sont exigeants au change
au port les dates qui sont modérés
est-ce qu'on peut raccourcir d'une
certain temps il ya toute une
quantification
une analyse ok maintenant le rapport ce
matin la vérificatrice générale dit que
le ministère des transports de la
difficulté à recruter du personnel à
évaluer des travaux a estimé tous les
coups je vous fait entendre un petit
extrait de guylaine leclerc ont fait une
mauvaise évaluation un d'aider des
projets on ne fait pas une supervision
adéquate décidé à des situations qui
sont faits par les firmes externes alors
nos constats demain donc il ya plusieurs
de nos constats qui demeure et ça risque
de s'amplifier avec l'augmentation de
travaux d'infrastructures qui va y avoir
un futur ça risque de s'amplifier avec
l'augmentation des travaux
d'infrastructures ce que vous faites la
vérificatrice générale dit que ça va
amplifier les problèmes au ministère des
transports est pas les régler mais
monsieur dubé si on continue de faire la
même façon qu'on faisait part de penser
qu'ils auraient à nos clients des
commentaires on a regardé avec new skies
comment on est efficace donne un exemple
à l'intérieur du ministère on a engagé
beaucoup de personnel au cours des deux
dernières années parce qu'il fallait
regarder d'expertisé dans les rangs en
suivant je pense que les commandes table
avec catastrophe à propos mais nous
avons changé certaines choses
nous allons travailler différemment on
n'est pas obligé toujours d'aller au
plus bas soumissionnaire est ce qu'on
peut travailler avec des facteurs de
qualité qui nous permettent de mieux
choisir des genres équipe est à votre
mieux qualifier les projets pour être
certain que l'estimé qu'on fait
et mieux il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont changé au cours des deux dernières
années qui vont faire qu'on va être
capable d'avoir la même rigueur mais
plus dé j avais vous évaluez vous me
parliez du télétravail tantôt il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensent qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui vont
rester en télétravail qui ne vont pas se
déplacer en automobile avant d'accélérer
des projets routiers l'a35 l'a19 la 73
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez évalué
l'effet du télétravail sur youtube
a sion d'être réseau routier en fait il
faut regarder vous regardez à court
terme c'est une chose mais il faut
regarder aussi un moyen et à long terme
je pense que lorsqu'on travaille avec
des mesures comme par exemple des voies
réservées aux autobus ou des choses
comme ça c'est dit c'est dit encore une
fois c'est des meilleurs et ses corps ou
dans toutes les grandes villes qui vont
être là après l'atterrisage nord vous
allez voir dans le type de projet que
londres choisie et qui vont faire
surtout aux améliorations en demande il
va tenir compte non seulement de l'est
la crise l'après crise et d'avoir une
vue à long terme et c'est d'ailleurs ce
sont des projets de constituer des
projets qui ont besoin de prévisibilité
pour les 10 15 20 prochaines années
et si pour ce qui est important ne va
vous qu avait les deux mains dans le
trésor public monsieur dubé est ce qu'on
s'en va vers des restrictions la rigueur
de l'austérité budgétaire dans les
dépenses pour revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire d'ici trois à cinq ans un
mot-clé ministre des finances a été très
clair je ne suis ici il n'y aura pas de
mesures d'austérité on est entré dans
cette crise avec des finances publiques
qui était après mon état on a dit qu'on
était chanceux d'avoir cette condition
nord
si sûr qu'on vit une crise en ce moment
mais on a la capacité de 20 des
investissements dont on a on a dit qu'on
allait respecter le cadre des budgets
qu'on avait développé aussi connu des
surcoûts en santé on y travaille mais il
y aura pas de mesures de sécurité qu'on
est capable de passer à tabac et comme
le dit m me suggéra de revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire sur un horizon
qu'il pourra expliquer lors des mises à
jour à la fin du parfait merci beaucoup
que celle du bea québec merci
aussi monsieur fillion 23 rien